Bon dia des de Murgap. Són les 12 del matí i avui és dijous 10 de setembre de 2026.
Sí, avui esteu veient aquest vídeo el mateix dia que el gravo.
El motiu l'entendreu ara quan us expliqui una cosa, que és que he tingut un contratemps i us el vull explicar.
Vosaltres decidireu si és un contratemps greu o no.
A part d'això, ja que m'estic enrotllant, us explicaré una mica el viatge per si hi ha algú nou que no s'ha enterat molt bé de quina és la ruta i tal.
Però abans de tot, què va passar ahir? Ahir no vaig gravar vídeo.
Ja us vaig dir que estava sent un dia molt dur abans d'ahir mentalment per mi.
Llavors vaig decidir que el dia després, és a dir, ahir, no gravaria vídeo perquè a més seria tot el dia igual.
I sí, va ser tot el dia.
I semblant a l'últim vídeo que heu vist, que és rectes infinites, paisatge desèrtic.
Hi ha algun moment que va haver-hi un riu de color verd així maco, amb l'herba verda i tal.
He fet alguna foto. Això va ser maco.
I l'arribada a Murgab, doncs també hi ha aquest riu, una zona molt plana, amb molts meandres, també va ser bastant maco.
Però va ser un dia duríssim, duríssim també mentalment, físicament, perquè venia d'haver caminat molt.
El dia anterior també vaig fer 50, doncs ahir vaig fer 53.
El fet d'haver campat a 4.100 metres tampoc ajuda. Vaig passar una mica de fred, no gaire.
Vaig estar molt petat físicament, però havia d'aconseguir-ho. Havia de venir a Murgab.
Havia d'arribar, perquè no volia acampar a 10-15 quilòmetres d'aquí.
I bueno, ho vaig aconseguir i vaig arribar a aquesta guest house, d'acord, on he passat la nit.
I la intenció?
Us vaig dir?
Us vaig dir, el vídeo anterior, que era el que queda fins a la Xina, començar avui per la tarda, fer 20 quilòmetres,
demà divendres fer 40 fins a una estació de camioners que poden passar ja a la nit,
i l'últim dia, dissabte, fer els 27 quilòmetres que queden fins a Culmapàs.
La teoria és molt maca, però...
Però, bueno, ahir vaig estar aquí a la guest house sopant, no?, sopant amb els altres hostes.
I ja m'està xerrant, va estar molt bé. Va estar molt bé poder xerrar amb altra gent, des dels italians,
aquells que em vaig trobar, que no feia una xerrada allò llarga i explicant moltes coses,
i que no és una cosa de pim-pam, de trobar algú pel camí i fas una entrevista, tal, no?, és una cosa més llarga.
I, bueno, en algun moment va sortir el tema que jo aniria per Culmapàs, tal, i em va dir, escolta,
ja estàs segur que aquesta frontera no tanca el cap de setmana?
I jo, ostres, no ho havia tingut en compte, això.
Ho miro, i sí.
Està oberta per camions, però per turistes tanca dissabte i diumenge.
Tonto de mi, perquè això ho havia previst abans.
Sí, això ho hauria mirat, és que...
Molt burro, molt burro.
Llavors, clar, em trastoco els plans, perquè si surto avui, ja et dic, arribo dissabte,
i dissabte estarà bé.
La frontera tancada.
Si surto demà, arribaria diumenge, que també està la frontera tancada.
Per tant, he de sortir dissabte per poder creuar la frontera dilluns.
Això vol dir que m'estaré aquí, a Murgap, a aquesta Guescaus, dos nits més de les previstes.
Això, per una banda, està bé perquè...
A veure, un dia, si hagués sigut un dia de descans, dius, mira, la veritat és que ho necessitava,
perquè estava molt cansat, tenia algunes pals dels peus bastant adolorides,
i un dia de descans, doncs mira, està bé.
Dos dies, em toca una mica la pera.
Em toca una mica la pera perquè el meu descans llarg, entre cometes, de dos o tres dies,
el volia fer quan ja estigués a la Xina, a Trajnogar, o com es digui el poble aquest on passaré.
No aquí, a Tajikistan, que és un país que m'està agradant molt, però hi ha coses que no,
i estic cansat ja d'algunes coses a Tajikistan que tinc ganes de sortir, especialment el menjar.
Menjar m'està avorrint molt.
I bueno, la Xina, com que estaré poc a la Xina, m'agradaria fer-hi una parada més llarga, menjar més menjar xinès.
És igual.
Al principi, quan vaig veure això, va entrar una mica d'ostres, tu, saps?
Una mica de quin pal, dos dies, però bueno.
Després, al final, he relativitzat perquè no passa res.
Estic tenint sort amb la meteo, i he enviat la meteo a llarg termini, i és bastant estable.
Un grau, dos graus més, menys.
La diferència entre arribar dissabte a Kulmapas o arribar a dilluns, meteorològicament parlant, no hi ha gaire diferència.
I a més, si us en recordeu dels vídeos que vaig fer a principis de Tajikistan,
jo vaig dir que el meu objectiu, o sigui, jo tenia previst més o menys creuar Kulmapas el 14 o el 16, si no recordo malament, de setembre.
I avui estem a dia 10, i el creuaré el dia 14.
Per tant, bueno, són dos dies que he guanyat.
I llavors, al final, pues, lo comido por lo servido, que diuen en castellà, no?
Llavors, doncs això, us volia informar d'això que passaria.
I, bueno, què faré? Doncs avui res. Avui no faré res. Avui vull anar a situ, descans absolut.
Llavors, bueno, sí, ara aniré al container market, al market de Murgab, que és una ciutat, com podeu veure, digue-li ciutat, digue-li d'això.
Però, bueno, sí, és relativament gran. Comprar de les altres ciutats.
Però, bueno, sí, és relativament gran comprar de les altres ciutats, digue-li d'això. Però, bueno, sí, és relativament gran comprar de les altres ciutats.
Però, bueno, sí, és relativament gran comprar de les altres ciutats.
Però, bueno, sí, és relativament gran comprar de les altres que he vist del Pamir.
Aquestes cases tan baixes, tal, no imagino qui hi hiverni, com deus ser.
I, bueno, els serveis... Ahir no em vaig poder dutxar perquè, per exemple, no funcionava la electricitat. Aquest matí sí.
És molt precari, i també et diria que fa pena que el govern no inverteixi en aquesta zona, no?
Coses bàsiques com il·luminació del carrer, no sé, que no se'n vagi la llum cada dos per tres.
Llavors aniré al mercat de containers a veure què hi ha.
És un conjunt de containers on cada container és una botiga.
I vull a veure si em puc trobar un barber per tallar-me la barba,
que ja va tocant en primer lloc.
I en segon lloc, jo a la foto de la visa en Paquistan estava sense barba.
No era que importi gaire, però prefereixo no anar amb una superbarba
i que se'm vegi similar al visat de Paquistan.
Visat de Paquistan que, per altra banda, encara no m'ha arribat.
L'ambaixador em va dir que el tindria, però que tardaria una mica.
Ostres, ja no em queda gaire per Paquistan.
Si he d'esperar un munt de dies, tocaria bastant la pera.
Especialment tenint en compte que la frontera aquesta és molt freda
a mesura que van passar els dies.
També potser per això no és negatiu que quedi aquí dos dies més
per esperar el visat de Paquistan.
Bé, doncs a veure si puc tallar-me la barba.
I, bueno, dinar alguna cosa que no sigui plof i sopa,
que ahir vaig sopar aquí i que està bé.
No està malament el que et donen aquí en aquesta gèscau, està bastant bé.
Bastant barata la gèscau, 15 euros la nit, que altres són 25.
I és bastant còmoda.
He compartit habitació amb un altre home, però no he fet cap soroll,
he dormit bastant bé.
Ara estic sol perquè els ciclistes ja han anat.
Suposo que aquesta nit vindrà més gent.
Però sí, no, hi ha bastantes habitacions i potser estic sol.
Aquesta nit, no ho sé.
Què més?
I, bueno, doncs sí, també he d'estar vigilant el que em gasto
perquè jo pensava que aniria molt sobrat de diners
i no ho vaig tan sobrat.
Em queden uns, diria que,
una mica menys de 100 euros.
Llavors, comptant que avui i demà dinar alguna cosa per aquí,
a la parada de camionet, suposo que hauré de pagar per dormir ja
i per dinar i hauré de comprar provisions
i el barbé, doncs, bueno, no em queda tan poc.
Però sí que em queda suficient com per demà
m'agradaria fer una cosa.
Bé, ja que tinc un dia extra, no? Tinc un dia d'això.
M'agradaria gastar-me els diners per anar al llac Caracull.
Què és que es diu així? És un nom bastant curiós.
És el llac que està en direcció a Kirguistà.
Clar, a mi això no em ve de camí.
No ho anava a veure.
Però, ja que tinc un dia extra,
molaria anar.
M'han dit que el taxi costa 50 euros,
cosa que és massa car.
Però si puc compartir un taxi, o sigui, un...
Són cent i pius quilòmetres.
És bastant llarg, per tant, s'entén el preu, no?
Però si puc compartir un taxi amb alguna altra persona
o algo així que surti més barato,
hi aniré.
Si he de pagar 50 euros, no.
No hi aniré.
Llavors aquesta seria l'excursió del dia de demà.
I bueno, així estan les coses.
Al final, doncs mira, ja està.
Un dia més aquí, dos dies més aquí i no passa res.
Vale, l'itinerari.
L'itinerari, bueno, doncs,
per si encara ningú sap,
vaig volar des de Tbilisi fins a Samarkand, a Uzbekistan,
he creuat tot Tajikistan
i ara he d'anar fins a Kulmapas.
De Kulmapas, un petit tram de la Xina,
fins a la frontera amb Pakistan,
que és la frontera més alta del món,
i des d'allà baixaré la carretera del Karakorum
fins a Islamabad
i des d'Islamabad aniré fins a Lahore,
la frontera amb l'Índia.
Malauradament aquesta frontera no la puc creuar.
Llavors hauré d'agafar un avió a un país intermig,
potser a Uzbekistan,
perquè crec que les connexions són barates.
No hi ha vols directes entre Pakistan i Índia,
per això he de fer això. Llavors, simplement,
agafar un avió a Uzbekistan, després tornar a la Índia.
A la Índia probablement
faci un descans llarg,
perquè potser ve algú a visitar-me.
No ho tinc clar encara, però potser sí.
I aniria fins a l'altra banda
de la frontera amb Pakistan,
seguiria caminant des del punt on ho he deixat.
Llavors aniria fins als Himalayas indis
i després creuaré cap al Nepal
i faré tot el Nepal.
Després sortiré del Nepal,
aniré a la Índia a un petit tram
i després entraré a Bangladesh, un país també molt raro.
I des de Bangladesh agafaré un avió
per saltar-me a Mianmar, perquè és
en guerra civil, no pots passar per allà.
I aniré fins a Tailàndia.
A Tailàndia caminaré fins a
Singapur, passant per Malèixia.
A Tailàndia no sé si
començaré des del nord, des de Chiang Mai
o des de Bangkok, perquè les últimes setmanes
han sortit notícies, bueno, notícies oficials,
vull dir, han endurit el tema
dels visats a Tailàndia, ja són més curts,
no pots agafar-te 90 dies,
no pots fer tants vissarrans, llavors crec que
només podré fer 60 dies.
Crec que per tot el país 60 dies
potser és una mica justet.
Llavors potser faig només per això des de Bangkok.
Però bé, encara queda molt, molt, molt, molt
per això. Aquesta serà la meva ruta
per àsia. Tempos.
Doncs, a veure, jo estaré
5 dies més aquí a Tajikistan,
després posaré una setmana
com a molt, molt, molt a la Xina.
Llavors,
el dia, doncs,
20 i pico creuaré la frontera amb Pakistan.
A Pakistan són uns 3.100 quilòmetres fins
a la frontera amb Índia.
Per tant, això és un mes i mig, per tant
jo crec que a principis de novembre,
principis de novembre
o meitats de novembre, hauria d'estar
a la Índia. Ja ho veurem també
perquè a Pakistan no ho vull prendre tant a saco
perquè a Tajikistan he anat
molt, molt, molt a full. Dies de 40
i pico, 50 quilòmetres, pocs dies de descans,
a Pakistan m'ho vull
prendre una mica més relaxat. Per tant, bueno, ja
veurem. Però sí, potser mitjans de novembre.
Després crec que a la Índia
són potser dues setmanes o
tres més els 20 dies aquests
o dues setmanes que faré de descans. Per tant,
potser mes i mig. Per tant,
em plantaria a Nepal
al desembre.
No sé quant de desembre.
Potser principis
de gener, inclús. No sé.
I estaré tres mesos, jo crec,
a Nepal. Per tant, jo crec
que fins al març-abril
estaré al Nepal.
Després, fins
a la capital de Bangladesh,
Dakar, seria potser un mes més.
Llavors, això, abril-matx
potser
estaria volant a Tailàndia.
I de Tailàndia fins a Singapur,
doncs, pot ser que siguin tres mesos
més o dos.
No ho tinc clar. Però
potser acabaria a Àsia
al
l'agost
de l'any que ve. Per tant,
gairebé
d'aquí un any.
És molt difícil, a mesura que vaig
allunyant, és molt més difícil dir les dates,
no? Però sí, és la meva
previsió. Després d'aquí, doncs,
Austràlia, Nova Esglanda,
Nord-Amèrica, Sud-Amèrica... Encara queda molt.
D'acord,
doncs, aquesta és la xapa que
us volia fotre. Si demà
vaig al llac aquest, gravaré?
Crec que no. I si gravo
algú, serà allà pel vídeo del dia de després.
Sobre el tema
aquest dels vídeos, doncs, jo crec que
si aquí, aquí a Murgap, tinc 4G,
cap problema. Però crec que, a mesura que
vagi anant fins a Culmapàs, crec que deixaré
de tenir cobertura. Per tant,
potser el primer vídeo del que sortim de Murgap,
per tant, el proper vídeo després d'aquest,
ja no el pugui pujar fins que estigui a la Xina.
Si és que entro a la Xina, que aquesta és una altra
cosa, que la frontera aquesta, ja
veurem, eh? Ja veurem la frontera aquesta.
Eh?
Llavors sí, potser,
potser fins, fins
dilluns no teniu vídeo. No ho sé.
No ho sé. Com sempre,
això ja ho veurem. Potser hi ha
megafon a la parada aquesta de
de camioners. No, no ho sé.
Bueno, i ja que
estic donant-vos la xapa,
aprofitaré per dir-vos una cosa del tema
de les postals. Bueno, per
qui no ho sàpiga,
tinc una aixeta, que és com un Patreon,
i tu em pots donar suport cada mes,
si vols, i amb aquesta
aportació econòmica, si me la fas, doncs jo
a canvi t'envio una postal cada mes.
Ja hi ha més de 500 persones apuntades,
i, bueno,
la estic enviant cada mes, cap problema,
és feina, però, bueno, us agrada,
per tant, us segueixo enviant, i us arriben,
us estan arribant. La
d'Uzbekistan la vaig enviar a principis de
setembre, no, a principis d'agost.
Aquesta va ser la postal
d'agost.
Llavors, la de setembre, Tadjikistan
no l'envio, perquè
no confio en el sistema
de correus de Tadjikistan,
i, a més, aquí, ara on estic, a Murgat,
no hi ha, no hi ha postals,
per tant, no seria possible.
Llavors, la de setembre la vull enviar des de
Pakistan, perquè a la Xina
no aniré fins a cap
ciutat principal on puguin tenir postals.
El poble aquest
de Trasnogar crec que és un poble que no
hi ha res, no?, i molt menys coses turístiques.
Llavors l'enviaré des de Pakistan.
Què passa? Clar, jo a Pakistan, al nord
de Pakistan, dubto que trobi postals.
No ho sé, Pakistan no és un país gens turístic.
Per tant, dubto
que trobi postals. Jo crec que fins a
Islamabad no trobaré postals.
No ho sé. Però clar, Islamabad probablement
no arribi fins a l'octubre.
Però no passa res.
Vull dir,
jo l'últim dia de setembre
agafaré la llista, me la guardaré,
i quan trobi les postals a l'octubre
o quan sigui, us les enviaré.
La setembre, les postals
de setembre les enviaré a l'octubre. Com ja
va passar, si no recordo malament,
a Georgia. O a
Turquia, no recordo. A Turquia.
Llavors, bueno, la postal la rebreu, espero,
però la rebreu tard.
La diferència entre la postal d'Uzbekistan
i la postal de Pakistan serà en molts mesos.
Però no us preocupeu, perquè també les enviaré.
I després, llavors, la d'octubre quan l'enviaré?
Doncs potser des de
Pakistan també, però des de Lahore, en comptes d'Islamabad.
No ho sé. O potser ja des de la Índia,
si és que arribo a la Índia a l'octubre.
O potser a principis de novembre l'envio a la Índia.
I també vaig en retras. Llavors
envio dos des de la Índia, no? Potser una des de
Delhi i una altra des d'un altre lloc.
Jo què sé. Ja ho veurem.
Però bueno, no us preocupeu
que la tindreu.
Això seria una mica
l'actualització
del
dia.
Costa respirar una mica, he de dir.
Només fer un petit esforç
d'aixecar-se, no sé què, ja
costa l'aire, perquè estic això
a tres mil i pico metres. Costa l'aire
però no he tingut en cap moment mal
d'altura. Jo mareig ni mal de cap
ni res. Per tant crec que estic
bastant ben aclimatitzat.
Molt bé, senyors. Doncs fins la propera
que no sé quan serà.
Adéu.